we have a major update this morning
about our ongoing CBS News investigation
into reports of carbon monoxide seeping
into Ford Explorers the automaker is now
offering free repairs 1.3 million owners
of the popular SUV will begin receiving
notices today they affect models from
2011 to 2017 but the automaker is
stopping short of recalling the Explorer
the watchdog group the center for auto
safety says anything short of a recall
is not enough CBS News has learned the
number of complaints is growing Kris Van
Cleave has been tracking this for the
last year and he is in Washington Chris
good morning good morning here is the
letter Ford sent out on Monday talking
about this piece of mind customer
satisfaction program the repairs involve
reprogramming the air conditioner
checking drainage valves along the back
of the vehicle and then checking all of
the seals here along the rear of the
vehicle this as the number of complaints
we have learned continues to grow
calling it quits
Steve Simmons unloads his tools from the
2015 Ford Explorer he bought used just a
couple of weeks earlier he made the
dealer buy it back after he says he got
sick behind the wheel nausea headaches
dizziness blurred vision after taking
blood tests Simmons doctor diagnosed him
with carbon monoxide poisoning what
would have happened to me and my wife we
would have been asleep off the road
doing at least 70 or 75 miles an hour
while we were doing it you really think
this could have killed you 100% not a
doubt in my mind the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration is
investigating at least 1.3 million
2011 to 2017 Ford Explorers based on
reports of exhaust which contains carbon
monoxide
seeping into the passenger cabin nearly
1300 people have filed complaints with
the regulator and Ford acknowledged
getting more than 2,000 reports as of
August last year in the letter to
customers
Ford insists explorers are safe and its
investigation has not found carbon
monoxide levels that exceed what people
are exposed to everyday Nitsa says it's
found no actual evidence of carbon
monoxide poisoning that's just by
documented
cases like Louisiana police officer
brandy sickie who is now suing fort and
Simmons both were diagnosed after
driving an explorer Simmons just
launched Ford Explorer nightmare dot-com
hoping to rally support for a recall
what's it gonna take before decisive
action is taken now I know it's a lot of
money for Ford but I mean you know put a
value on human life Nitsa will not talk
about the timeline for its investigation
but did tell us it remains very
concerned about this potential safety
issue adding that the actions by Ford
here with this program they do not bring
closure to the Nitsa investigation the
agency is urging people who get this
letter to call their car dealer Gale
questions remain there thank you very
much Chris